UI Socken und so bunte nein nein
her das das glaubt in ihre Familie nie
sehen Sie die die Freude über die Socken
das muss aufrichtig sein ja wie kriege J
J an Weihnachten Socken eben und jedes
Jahr freuen sie sich noch mehr darüber
aber das müssen wir üben deswegen sind
sie ja
hier also noch mal noch mal aber diesmal
diesmal mit ein bisschen mehr
Ektase ja Wahnsinn Socken und in so
vielen Farben die kommen ja zu allem
tragen nein Stopp nein
nein wo sind die Emotionen wo ist der
Ausdruck die
Haltung üben
benüüü Schauspielschule rknecht das Last
Minute Training für ihre Bescherung
jetzt
buchen Socken und so herrliche Farben
diese diese prach
polyryl entschuldig jetzt
bissinen Schauspielschule rupknecht für
echte Freude unterm Weihnachtsbaum
zaubern Sie Ihrer Familie ein Lächeln
ins Gesicht es lohnt
[Musik]
sich